you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news
on today's programme global temperatures
tick up as scientists prepared the most
comprehensive
update on global climate research in six
years
more flooding in england and around the
world as scientists say we need
better education on climate change
impacts
and how one city in canada is using
parkland and trees to adapt
to extreme weather events
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions
and we start today with these numbers
here on our data dashboard because
as global warming ticks up and the world
experiences
fire floods and heat waves scientists
are meeting to finalise one of the most
comprehensive
and influential reports on climate
change in
years the intergovernmental panel on
climate change assessment will update
the science around greenhouse gas
emissions and projections
for future warming and as the scientists
meet so too do ministers with the
president of cop 26 alex sharma
holding discussions ahead of the un
summit being held in glasgow in november
our climate correspondent hannah thomas
peter reports
extreme weather events unfolding around
the world
a dramatic backdrop for ministers
gathering at a uk hosted meeting on
climate change
amid floods and storms they are
preparing for a crucial summit happening
later in the year
known as cop26 the pressure is on to
deliver
and keep the worst effects of global
warming at bay
ultimately there is not going to be
anywhere to hide at cop
26. each of us will be in the spotlight
what actual progress has been made in
the last few days
to persuade countries like china and
india and south africa
to do more to reduce their emissions
sooner
until today we were not clear whether
there was this common understanding that
uh
out of the cop there there needs to be a
package of decisions and actions the
homework is not yet done but we
we are we are on our way
there are still real sticking points
rich countries have failed to deliver
promised climate funding
and developing nations are getting fed
up
i've spent so much time
putting ourselves getting ourselves
ready now it's time for action
money is not the only problem that uk
government negotiators are scrambling to
solve
there are dozens of countries involved
in the negotiations around cop26
and a lot of them want different things
there still isn't
agreement for example on phasing out the
use of new coal-fired power plants
now that might sound like a detail but
it's the kind of thing that could derail
the summit
if it isn't sorted out and quickly just
a few days ago
coal was the issue that stumped a
meeting of g20 ministers
climate experts say there's no more room
for disagreements
time is not on our side so that's why
it's so important this is the moment
when we've committed to action
we can take action and where delay is
deeply dangerous
our vulnerability to climate change is
becoming increasingly apparent
a lot is riding on cop26 its success
is far from certain hannah thomas peter
sky news westminster
well joining me now for more on this is
professor sir david king
former permanent special representative
for climate change and founder of the
climate crisis advisory group
welcome to you first of all how
important is this upcoming ipcc report
and what kind of impact
do you think it could have everybody
turns
to the ipcc report as the definitive
document from the scientific community i
i think it is therefore critically
important
and i do believe that what we're going
to see at this report
is a much clearer message
about the dire situation we're in
so i think i think it is important um
but we've all got to remember that the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change
is a an international report
it has 195 nations that are contributors
or
nominally contributors and it's a very
painstaking process
i admire the way it's conducted i admire
those who work on it
but it is not the most agile body in the
world
and so the report itself how significant
a role do you think that will play
in the run-up to cop 26. the climate
crisis
month-on-month gets more and more
challenging frankly we have run out of
time
and we need to be on some kind of a i
don't like the phrase but
some kind of a war footing if we are
going to make real progress
are we anywhere near that i think we
might be in a better place than we have
in the past for one simple reason
john kerry leading the negotiations on
behalf of the
united states of america who i know well
because i was doing the same for britain
in two thousand and fifteen and
uh leading the negotiations from china
these are the two biggest emitters in
the world
china has done in my view much more
on trying to switch across to non-fossil
fuel energy usage
over the last 10 years than the united
states has
but nevertheless both countries are
committed to real action
and these two countries really can play
a global leadership role in a way that
we've not had before
imagine britain leading the way
in the world on on negotiations now we
did a good job
i don't think the paris agreement would
have been reached without that
but nevertheless we are not the big
country that can lead the way with these
two doing it
it is possible and of course they're
working closely with the european union
and with our own alex sharma here in
britain so i
i think there is a better chance arising
from this
of progress but my goodness we've got a
long way to go
professor david king thanks very much
indeed
thank you let's take a look now at the
day's other climate news and
uk housing is amongst the least energy
efficient in europe
but the national residential landlords
association has called
government plans to make rented homes
more efficient a pipe dream
it says more funding is needed if
ministers want privately rented
properties
to have a minimum energy performance
rating of c
from 2025. the proposal could cut the
country's collective energy bill
by 5.1 billion pounds each year
through things like better insulation
and double glazed windows
gardeners at britain's oldest botanical
garden are sowing the seeds for a warmer
future
fig and olive trees are being planted at
the oxford botanics domestic garden
where the rock gardens have already been
adapted to resemble an eastern
mediterranean landscape
rising temperatures mean the familiar
english garden will become
harder to maintain and a cockatoo
species
could soon be listed as endangered
despite being considered a bird of least
concern just a few years ago
the gang gang cockatoo is found in
southeastern australia
an area badly hit by the 2020 australian
bushfires
which reduced numbers by a fifth the
threatened species scientific committee
says bushfires caused by climate change
will continue to destroy the cockatoo's
habitats and nesting sites
the met office is forecasting more
thunderstorms in england and scotland
this week
nearly a month's worth of rain fell in
one day yesterday flooding homes roads
and underground stations in london
the torrential rain followed
record-breaking temperatures earlier in
the week
scientists predict that a key
characteristic of climate change is a
shift towards
extreme weather and recent events here
as well as floods in europe
china and india show how important it is
to understand climate change
so that we can deal with its impacts and
adapt in the future
well let's bring in professor andrew
charlton perez head of meteorology at
the university of reading
first of all should we be surprised do
you think by the flooding events we've
seen in recent weeks in china and europe
and
and yesterday in london were the warning
signs there
there haven't been any attribution
studies for these particular events yet
but we know
physically that we would expect there to
be more moisture in the atmosphere and
for there to be perhaps more of these
extreme events in fact the the latest
climate
projections from the met office to show
an increase in these
kind of extreme thunderstorms and so um
there's certainly something i think we
will need to
to prepare for in the future well yes
and you're part of the climate
education summit which is trying to
address how climate change is taught
so how important do you think education
is in
understanding climate change and
learning to adapt to it in the future
well we think it's it's vital we're
really excited to partner with a number
of
other organizations that see the need
for young people to
understand uh the the drivers of the
changing climate and understand how to
adapt to
exactly these kinds of extreme uh
weather events and we we'd very much
like
uh lots of people to to join us at our
summit will be entirely online
on september the 15th so um if you if
you search for climate education summit
university of reading you'll find us and
please do come along and share your view
with us
well yes and what might people learn if
floods are to become more severe and
more frequent what can we do
to adapt
so there are lots of ways of course we
can we can prepare ourselves and
and our governments can can prepare the
the
urban drainage systems and and prepare
our local environments in cities to to
deal with with larger amounts
of water and also we should prepare
ourselves to
to take um precautions and adjust to the
risk check on our neighbors
make sure we we have a plan in case of
extreme weather and and to
um be able to move our possessions and
those kinds of things
andrew charlton paris thanks very much
indeed
thank you now although we've seen severe
flooding in countries around the world
in recent weeks there are stories of
hope too mississauga in canada sits on
the banks of lake ontario and extreme
weather events there
are being made more intense and frequent
due to climate change
so officials decided to try and mitigate
the risks
here's how the city is being transformed
we have had floods we've had ice storms
significant wind storms which of course
takes down trees
we've had extreme heat
[Music]
we estimate the cost to be about half a
billion dollars to
uh over the next decade along but one
severe ice storm could range from 23
million
to 38 million we have 62 stormwater
management ponds in the city of
mississauga now
and what these ponds do is to help us
control storm water quality
and water quantity we're on the shores
of lake ontario and we have a number of
lakeside parks that doors the water into
the ground
over 40 000 trees shrubs wildflowers and
grasses
are planted annually we are wanting to
plant one million trees
across the city so that again it absorbs
the water
[Music]
measures like roof drainage control
permeable pavement
storm water ponds here what you're
seeing is the energy dissipator which is
the outlet of the stormwater management
pond
i think the key message is just really
um applying a climate lens to decision
making
and leadership i think that you know we
can't do this without strong leadership
well that's everything from us for today
on tomorrow's show building progress
towards reducing emissions from concrete
thanks for watching see you then
you